here we are in overtime let's see good
tonight
Louie do you have any suggestions for
keeping a family together in this era of
hyper partisan politics well yeah I mean
you kind of bridge the divide you're a
Midwestern boy but yeah buddy slicker
now I think you know like I visit home I
go back to Minnesota eight to ten times
a year which is a lot but I work a lot
there but I always see my brothers and
sisters all the time even the time even
the times when you don't have time you
got to check in and I think it's about
checking in and keeping people a part of
your life I'm talking right I mean yeah
not good people all that keep talking
and yeah even if you're mad at them or
they're mad at you don't let them run
away from you and don't let them hide
okay
Geraldo after all the work you did
exposing mental institutions like
Willowbrook what do you really think
about Trump declaring we need to reopen
these institutions well I think that
there as governor Spitzer knows there's
a there's a confusion in the public mind
between people who are mentally ill
which includes schizophrenia
post-traumatic stress you know block
bipolar that's different from my area
which is the developmentally disabled
mentally the Eskil mentally [ __ ]
down syndrome autistic people who were
we're housed in institutions not right
asylums but they were warehouses that
exists if people forget over 5,000
people
Kennedy's put there and lobotomy and all
the rest of it it was it just horrible
horrible treatment of people one has
kind of normal IQ and there's something
off and those are the people who like
running down the street with with guns
or things that look like guns and then
the the developmentally disabled or
people whose IQs are below normal who
you want to have as most humane living
environment as possible they're gentle
people they are misleading but they can
be you know get vocational training they
can evolve they can live longer rather
than being in institutions where 60 of
them were Jam
room naked smeared with their own feces
unattended one attendant for 60 people
so I asked one more Trump thing then
when he did that thing
it was terrible okay do you believe that
the US has learned from our experience
in Vietnam terrific book by the way
great writer legend highly you believe
that the US has learned from our
experience in Vietnam or that we are
continuing to make many of the same
mistakes obviously not in Vietnam but I
assume this person means somewhere else
unfortunately I think we continue to
make a lot of the same mistakes and this
is a frustration for me as a historian
you can study the history you can draw
the lessons but getting people to
actually internalize them and act upon
them is something else and for example
today across the Middle East when we're
fighting the war on terrorism I think
there's a tendency to think especially
on the part of the president that
American bombs and bullets will win the
day and there was a similar tendency in
Vietnam to think we could bomb the
Vietcong into submission general william
Westmoreland thought we could kill the
Vietcong faster and they could be
replaced and the guy that I wrote about
Edward Lansdale said no this is never
going to work out the only way to win is
to have a viable in state aid government
and set in South Vietnam that the people
can actually support and today we're not
really focused on creating governments
that people can support across the
Middle East we're just focused on
bombing and then leaving and that's not
going to be a successful long term
strategy yeah I know he talks about Isis
being annihilated but there may be
annihilated in Syria but they're just
gonna take their talents to al-qaeda in
Iraq which was the predecessor of Isis
was annihilated by 2011 then President
Obama pulled our troops out of Iraq a
decision I opposed as a result of that
he created breathing space for Isis to
arise and to take this vast Caliphate
across Syria and Iraq and my concern is
that Trump today is going to repeat that
very same mistake that he and other
Republicans were criticizing not so long
ago you
also true if I might say that we always
look at our model as the model for other
countries and we have no idea who all
these tribal things and all the history
and I think we always try to get these
people to do things our way and they
don't have what we have to do that they
define freedom differently I mean that
was George Bush's big mistake he was
like everybody loves freedom we also
forget that it's all about religion in
the Middle East we don't understand that
the iights are different than the sunnis
we changed the order and the iraq
invasion of oh three unsettled the
society that had settled however maybe
unfair we could be perceived from people
in a democratic society but religion
rules in the Middle East it's been
forever
millennium it'll be corrupted in history
that happened six hundred years ago to
them is like yesterday yeah that's not
just the Middle East that's a lot of
countries know Yugoslavia when that
place fell apart you got to have
on-the-ground understanding like the guy
that I wrote about edlund's that we
spent years in the Philippines in
Vietnam and really came to understand a
society and he was trying to talk truth
to the power two generals who thought
they could just bomb their way to
victory but today I you know I see
unfortunately a similar mindset were
again there's not in the white house you
don't see a lot of people were very
worried about the dynamics of tribal
society in Iraq or Syria
you know Trump just wants the throat you
know bomb bomb them and in then think
that they were gonna win that way we
have the phrase wag the dog other
presidents have been accused of starting
wars to distract do you think Trump is
above that nothing that Trump is above
like what's the move
[Applause]
would you say something in that what
what you ignore is we get one president
at a time we get one president when he
succeeds the nation succeeds when he
fails the nation is failing when you a
li innate yourself from the government
and say nothing they do is worth a [ __ ]
then then the country that's not what
we're doing when I said we don't want
him to succeed what we're saying is that
his absence of fact-based decision bacon
rightness geraldo just pointed out the
decision to move the National Guard to
the border I view as a manifestation of
a bad week he wants to distract he does
something but not at this moment not
with your first did the same we all
wanted to succeed this guy won't but by
the way was the last have you said
something nice about the show okay when
was the last time when he made the when
Kim jong-un said let's meet and Trump
said great let's meet and all the
Liberals said that's crazy great and I
said no you know what these two guys
probably the two craziest people in the
world they might understand also
supported moving the capital to
Jerusalem and so believe me I am
perfectly capable of bringing you nobody
does so another one that's important the
tariffs you know what Democrats should
stand up and say you know what it's time
we stood up against China we should do
it as a global coalition not as one-off
deals somebody had to stand up to China
was gaming this is wait a second I don't
think Democrats ought to be supporting
Trump's it's trying to start a trade war
with China this is not gonna work out we
need to stand up to China and trade that
time somebody's right Elliott what do
you think of Republicans deregulating
the banks and some Democrats deregulated
in the bank
well here's the thing I'll say it's been
so many years since we had a financial
crisis don't
it is the same goal ten years it's been
a single most moronic policy move I've
seen since moving the National Guard's
border it is I mean the fact that ten
years after the crisis we want to go
back and recreate the very predicate to
the crisis of oh wait just makes no
sense banks are lending their lending
enough the economy is booming why go
back to minimizing and limiting the
amount of capital they need it's insane
simply insane but it's also I completely
agree with you one of my happiest
moments in Washington DC they are few
was when I worked on the Wall Street
Reform Bill sat there at the bill
signing saw us really try to turn the
page from a time when the Wall Street
and the bank's wrote all of the rules
and the fact is they still are the
biggest donor to Democrats and
Republicans in the financial sector and
seeing that list of Democrats that
Elizabeth Warren had the guts to call
out that list of Democrats who were just
saying you know what let's deregulate
again let's go ahead and join with the
Republican caucus this is why the
Democratic Party is not as popular as it
needs to be with working in middle-class
people of all races all right thank you
very much everybody
[Applause]